we have native nur Ricci DS today and an
interception my line may block great and
the Kiwi got me the ball and everything
everything worked out fine so we did
good
great that's what it takes in football
all 11 players being on the same page
and executing at the same time doesn't I
dead no safety for the New England
Patriots won a Super Bowl been in the
NFL for years going on my fifth year
this year to sign another contract
he played actually fall USA is a 17 year
old rhyme you means so much to me we're
all wrapped up as an organization just
hoping that we can get to see among
metal snare
I grew up in Ohio my parents were
separated I live with my mom went to
school where she lived in Columbus spent
weekends in in summers with my dad
working in the junkyard in Springfield
Ohio growing up in a junkyard is
different at 15 he was driving a loader
he was smashing cars I think he learned
how hard work can be worked from the
morning until the evening right
alongside his dad me and my dad were
super tight we did everything together
from working in the junkyard to playing
sports I picked up rugby from my dad he
played for many many years as a young
kid six or seven years old going to his
games on Saturdays having him you know
toss it around with me it was something
I gravitated towards the bond between us
was already a strong one but it got even
stronger
obviously through rugby they were like
friends I mean Jeff certainly still
played the parental role if he felt Nate
was out of line but he also just enjoyed
him as a person all that experience I
had at such a young age developing a
skill set in passing and catching
coupled with being a decent athlete
allowed me to be pretty decent rugby
player throughout grade school high
school it got kind of serious for me
around the page of 16 and then getting
invited to USA under-19 team and going
to the Junior World Cup I kind of
stopped playing other sports
I didn't play football in high school
played rugby in college at Ohio State
I would say the NFL dream kind of came
around for me as I was nearing the end
of my Junior World Cups and rugby that
itch for football was still there
between not playing at all in high
school if any of my friends just being
at Ohio State the hype that football
gets there coupled with all the people
telling me I might be a good rugby
player but I could never play football
at Ohio State brought together and
enough of a desire for me to go after it
Nate trusted his dad totally so anything
that was going on in his mind he'd call
his dad
and I've voiced to him you know my
desire to play football because I had a
good rugby career going at the time and
to leave that just the playful bottle
hoste wasn't a good enough excuse so
after that conversation with him we kind
of set out a goal that I was gonna walk
onto a hoss day and I was gonna play in
the NFL and that's what I was bound to
determined to do I have learned one
thing from Nate and that's when he puts
his mind to it he usually succeeds so
when he was talking about the NFL I
wasn't surprised my dad was 2008 53 year
old Jeffrey Abner was found severely
beaten inside his business Thursday
night he's described as a family man who
was a champion rugby player Abner was
flown to Miami Valley Hospital and died
this afternoon
it was a robbery which led to his death
it was blunt-force trauma to the head
through the investigation there was a
piece of a pipe that was located in the
office area and which we believe that
that was the instrument that caused the
injury to mr. Abner
he was caught off guard attacked in a
violent manner I don't think anyone
should die like that for somebody to
commit a robbery you know to take
somebody's life over you know just a few
dollars it's horrific that was kind of
past the stage of him being you know a
father figure as much as he was more
just the best friend to me to lose him
so early like that obviously I heard and
it was you know hard to deal with and
put me in a bad place it's the worst
moment of your life I mean my my heart
just broke for him
I was sad for me but broke for him how
are you gonna let this affect you going
forward for the rest of your life how
are you gonna live
you know a positive life and then not
let this affect you that that was the
struggle I said Nate you have to live
your life you have so much life to live
and if your dad were standing next to me
he would not want to see he just would
not want to see you give up your life
because of this definitely was grateful
for the time that I had and the father
that I had and I was gonna make that
count for as much as I could
ended up making the team and that was
one step towards the angle of making it
to the NFL first time coming out of the
tunnel definitely felt like you know my
dad was with me my whole family was with
me to see him running through that
tunnel in front of that crowd was
surreal
the quickest way for me to get on the
field was through special teams
it was simple enough the balls kicked
off chase down the field and tackle the
guy with the ball my thing was if I had
more tackles than everybody else and
made a big enough impact on special
teams that a team would be willing to
pick me up and take a chance on me I
just wanted a shot you think about a
young man being a walk-on at Ohio State
and then after one year being the most
outstanding special teams player the cot
prototype Patriot Jack day comes along
and sure enough we can't build those
checks on the other one saying
congratulations you're your New England
Patriot he was the 197th pick he can
take pride in knowing he was picked two
places I had a Tom Brady who was the 190
ninth pick
I'm just being a part of the NFL and
winning Super Bowl and all that was just
another stamp on the journey that I've
had for me to here a couple years back
that it was gonna be reintroduced to the
Olympics growing up playing that sport
and it being such a big part of my life
how can you not want to be a part of
that how can you not want to be on that
team
the Patriots I think they just
understand that is on once in a lifetime
opportunity for me a lot of people talk
a lot but how many people go out and
execute on a dream
what you got with night is an
exceptionally powerful athlete he's a
hundred percent in you could see the
desire in his eyes and he goes out and
he empties the tank every time all the
time
I think my dad would have been smiling
ear-to-ear just to see everything that's
kind of happened he knows that he's
fulfilling something that probably his
dad would have loved to do he thinks
about him every day
he still has moments where I know he
wishes his dad or part of this be able
to see it and talk to him and give him
any kind of guidance he might want I'm
doing this for not only you know him or
not only myself and my friends and
family who followed my entire journey
it's really just kind of for everyone
and it's almost something I feel like
I'm meant to do I don't know that I can
really put into words what it would mean
to me to be fighting for a gold medal
and in real
Hey
would be amazing to say the least